this morning the nominees were announced
for the 89th Academy Awards and in
contrast to last year's slate that
provoked the oscarssowhite hashtag this
year features a diverse set of nominees
including a record six black actors then
again and again a record-tying 14
nominations also went to lala land which
is pretty much the whitest movie
imaginable I haven't seen it I don't I
don't know it just doesn't seem like a
movie I'm gonna see but what I hear I'm
just piecing this together I think it's
about Ryan Gosling explaining jazz Emma
Stone and I assume includes such songs
as I brought my own cloth bag to Whole
Foods and extra mild salsa please
the only thing whiter than lala land
will be a biopic about the invention of
mayonnaise which incidentally it's in
the works you guys Daniel day-lewis is
going to be amazing in this movie
amazing he pretended to be mayonnaise
for like six months to get ready for
this like so comedians what's an even
whiter musical than lala land okay the
Grand Wizard of Oz all right boys get
your uggs yes Katya how does succeed in
everything without really trying
[Applause]